friends make life good they provide the
scaffolding that makes it not just
bearable but fun they give us a sense of
meaning and purpose and are a source of
security self-esteem and happiness
almost nothing predicts how happy you
will be as how connected you feel and a
lack of social connection is associated
with a number of diseases and a shorter
life
but maybe you have scrolled through your
phone unsure who to call to go to a
movie with to celebrate with or ask for
comfort you may realize that you don't
have enough friends and feel lonely and
it's not just you disconnectedness and
loneliness are widespread many people
want more close friends but don't know
how to get them surprisingly nowadays
loneliness is highest among young people
whose relationships were also hit
especially hard by the global pandemic
social distancing stopped teens and
young adults from mingling in classrooms
clubs or dorms millions of friendships
may be lifelong friendships that might
have blossomed will never exist with
profound long-term consequences for our
Collective happiness the good news is
that it's not too late and there are
lots of friends to be found we'll mix
scientific information with actionable
advice in this video but we can't
address every individual situation
people cultures and schedules are
different if you suffer from chronic
loneliness you can also watch the video
we made about it
okay as with all important things in
life making friends is infuriatingly
simple but not necessarily easy but it
works through a few pretty
straightforward mechanisms
the most important thing about making
friends
people make friends with other people
when they spend casual time together
this is how our ancestors formed their
relationships because humans lived in
small close-knit communities in which
options for making friends were limited
so we just formed good relationships
with the people who were around us this
is why it's so easy to form new
friendships in school and University
Society locks you and your peers in a
building for several years you share
similar activities but more importantly
similar schedules overlapping and
fluctuating Social Circles form
naturally giving you regular Face Time
and shared experiences with many
different people
time to find others with similar World
Views or senses of humor
proximity can be more important than
similar interests
one study found that in student
dormitories the distance between rooms
was the strongest friendship predictor
living closer together meant a higher
chance of becoming friends
another study showed that being
physically present in a class A Lot
without saying a word makes others more
sympathetic to you
so the most important principle of
making friends is to regularly spend
time with people in the real world this
alone can make it happen automatically
and trumps all other advice but don't
forget that making friends is not a
numbers game or a competition don't
compare yourself to others everyone has
a social calibrator that can change as
you go through life maybe you were more
introverted as a teen but yearn for
Connection in your twenties maybe you
were part of sprawling Social Circles
but prefer fewer friends in your 30s
there is no right or wrong only right
for you
why we don't have enough friends
the main reason for a lack of
friendships is the simple fact that most
people don't prioritize friendships
nearly enough they don't realize until
it's too late that retaining friendships
Demands a regular energy and attention
although they are so important for
happiness friends often take a back seat
to other life decisions work commuting
romance or kids take up so much time and
energy that it's so much easier to crash
on your couch and lose yourself in
mindless activities especially as an
adult going for a bike ride getting
dinner or visiting a hobby store takes
much more mental effort and commitment
than it did after school when time ran
slower and energy and curiosity were
abundant
but it's not just adults who are too
busy for friends the average American
Teenager spends more time on Tick Tock
every day than socializing at parties
events or on the phone with friends
combined
established friendships don't require
the same time investment as early
friendships to keep up but they do
require some commitment
as life distracts you it's easy to skip
out on checking in when a friend goes
through exciting or depressing times
and so many friendships fade for lack of
attention Often by accident which is
extra tragic because there is never only
one person losing a friend it's always
at least two
another thing that makes many people
vulnerable is the way friendship
networks are structured the Friendship
Paradox is the phenomenon that on
average most people have fewer friends
than their friends which makes sense
since you're more likely to be friends
with someone who has many friends than
with someone who has few rather than
being densely interconnected friend
networks are often built around central
hubs so if central people disappear from
your life this can deprive you of many
connections at once and it can lead to a
distorted self-perception that you are
less popular than others although you
are perfectly average
it can get worse quickly with big life
Events maybe you move for school work or
love and are left without social
networks or you had a breakup that left
you with a smaller part of the formerly
shared social pie the reasons why you
find yourself with less connection than
you want are as diverse as people but
the underlying cause is almost always
time there is no shortcut to make new
friends and retain friendships you have
to prioritize relationships spend time
with people in real life and make them
feel that you care so take a look at
yourself and rebalance what you spend
your life doing
how to make new friends
Studies have shown that new friendships
can develop quite quickly weeks after
you meet someone
but it takes a few months for a casual
friendship to become a close
relationship with the biggest impediment
being time invested and the quality of
your interactions to make friends it
helps if you intentionally look for
people you have things in common with
and who are open to new relationships
you want to make it easy for yourself so
examine what kind of person you are
generally speaking extroverts tend to
Crave sensory stimulation spicier Foods
loud music or the excitement of engaging
a crowd introverts often confused with
shy people tend to be more sensitive to
sensory stimulants and prefer quieter
surroundings fewer people and even less
spicy food
places attract different people not
everybody can easily make friends at a
bar or a football game not everybody
finds a stroll through a park or a
bookstore stimulating men especially
form friendships around shared
activities but in general it's a good
idea to go to places that feel
comfortable where there are people you
might like who do things you find
interesting look for local clubs or
opportunities to volunteer check out
what hobby stores are around and dust
off your Space Marines or see if there
are new DND groups in your city and ask
if you could join one check Meetup apps
for gaming nights or wine tasting join a
sports club or look for people who go
hiking or want to cook together another
obvious Avenue is your professional life
it helps if you work in a job that
attracts people like you so you might
consider this when you choose a career
deepening your relationship with
colleagues can lead to Great friendships
especially if you look for peers and
there is no power imbalance and of
course there are friends you've lost
touch with you may be able to revive
some of these relationships in some
cases all it needs is a call or an
invitation research shows that more
often than not the other person will
appreciate that you've reached out
there are likely way more opportunities
to spend time with others than you are
aware of and if there aren't you can
take the initiative and create them
invitations are signals to start
friendships so bring people together by
having a dinner party organizing a
football game after work or starting a
board game group
everybody appreciates people who
organize fun things and the simple Act
of reaching out can kick-start a
self-propelling upward spiral of
well-being fun and connectedness that
can seriously improve the life of
everyone around you in meaningful ways
if you meet someone you Vibe with it's
pretty scary to make the first move but
they may feel the same way equally
interested in a friendship but also
blocked by fear of rejection so it's
worth going for it worst case they're
not interested which will sting for a
few hours but the best case could be a
lifelong friendship a risk well worth
the reward once you've formed early
connections check in whether they have
important things happening in their life
of course it's important not to be
overbearing but the more time you invest
the more opportunity you have to engage
in meaningful banter or silly jokes the
fact that friendships take time also
means that you need to be patient and
kind with yourself especially if you're
out of practice things will not improve
overnight but slowly step by step if you
keep up
open up Care and Share many people don't
have an issue being around others but
struggle to turn acquaintances into
friends
so let's talk about two important
principles that make it more likely that
you'll connect caring and sharing in
general our favorite topic is ourselves
and the things we care about because we
are literally at the center of our own
universe so people tend to like people
who are genuinely interested in them so
if you want to make friends your goals
should be trying to learn what makes
them tick just as important as caring
about others is reciprocity and openness
to connect you need to share the
experiences that made you you now you
don't want to overwhelm the other person
and immediately spill out your deepest
Secrets but open up a little and reveal
personal things because this also
signals to others that it's okay to do
the same the best case is that you find
shared experiences maybe you both had a
hard time in school maybe you share a
passion for weird movies
learning about others and sharing
personal stories in a balanced way and
not overdoing it is not an exact science
noticing the line between opening up and
over sharing requires practice and
depends on the vibe of the conversation
one of the perplexities of life is that
to get something it can be helpful to
convince yourself that you want it less
than you do in general it's good to be
laid back have fun and enjoy yourself do
things for yourself without expectations
but also be open to social opportunities
and accept invitations if they show up
and that's basically it
give friendships more priority in your
life check in with friends and regularly
go to things to have fun
show genuine interest in others and give
them the opportunity to know you without
selling yourself too hard if you do this
you're on track
if this sounds a bit scary the good news
is that human brains are hardwired to
seek connection It's Perfectly Normal to
seek out new friends and there are many
people who would welcome more close
relationships there are friendships up
for grabs everywhere and there are
plenty of people who will be so happy to
have you in their life as a good friend
go get to know them
we want to be part of your friendship
Journey so we've created a few things
you can share with new and old friends
two Wormhole pins to connect you and
your BFF no matter where you are if you
want to share something with your entire
friend group get a little bird pin for
each of them they're all unique but fit
together like pieces of a puzzle or get
matching posters to let your friends
know you're thinking of them or just
browse all the sciency things we made
for you if you like videos like this
getting something from our shop is the
best way to support us thank you for
watching
Queen
[Music]